يتم تداوله على نطاق واسع واستجاب له سكان
بلده كارخان الحدوديه مع سوريا يحاولون
العوده تدريجيا الى حياتهم الطبيعيه رغم
اثار الزلزال المحيطه بهم من كل جانب
يعني
من اجل مواصله الحياه والبقاء في البلاد
والحفاظ عليها رغم الزلازل ومخلفاتها يجب
علينا استئناف عملنا لتستمر الحياه
وسته
الاتيه الف نسمه نصفهم من السوريين
والله على الله شوفت عينك يعني
انشغل
الله يعزك هراديس شغلات مضبطين امورنا
وقبل زلزال كان وضعكم احسن والله
بيوتنا نفوت بيها
يعني نقول نجذب نفوت على البيت مثل
الحرامي ناخذ قرض ونطلع
هذه واحده من عشرات المساحات الجارفه
لتتحول الى مدن مؤقته الفحاويه ببلده
كارخان يتم تجهيزها لتكون مساكن صالحه
لاواء الاف المتضررين من ضحايا الزلزال
عبد القادر خربوش العربيه بلده كارخان على
الحدود التركيه السوريه